Jay has said enough is enough let's
settle here tonight pro wrestler Jay
Briscoe has died he was 38 years old
Delaware State Police said Jay and
another driver died following a head-on
collision on Tuesday his two daughters
were in the vehicle with him they were
taken to a hospital in critical
condition now following the news
tributes have poured in from the
wrestling world
Jay friscoe bringing Matt Hardy to his
feet
Bree and Nikki Bella offered prayers to
Jay's family on Twitter quote so
heartbreaking
the briscoes
[Music]
the national wrestling alliance called
Jay an amazingly talented man that we
are honored to have worked with villages
you know a lot of hard-working people
here man Jay and his brother Mark
performed as the Briscoe Brothers tag
team and they're not stopping yet
[Music]
Big E says the duo left an indelible
mark on tag team wrestling you talking
about one of the greatest tag teams of
all time and I'm saying that with no ego
11 times 18 Champion baby and Triple H
praised Jay for create getting a deep
connection with wrestling fans across
the globe
[Music]